Yeah,
first off just money and where you know
enough to pay teachers' salaries so that
low income districts are able to have
adequate education,
a more financial support,
uh,
for uh,
for college I did a comparison in
conscience of a liberal with the,
um,
with France and we know everybody knows
French do have real problems,
but everybody knows that young French
are much less likely to be working than
young Americans.
A lot of that is actually because the
French do things better.
Students are much less likely to be
forced to drop out of school for
financial reasons because there are good
government stipends.
Uh,
students from lower income families are
able to be full time students,
whereas in the United States they
usually have to work their way through
school.
And this is all good stuff.
There is a striking,
a statistical comparison I put in the
book that if you look at bright students
as measured by tests they took in the
eighth grade from low income families,
they're actually less likely to get
through college.
Then really not very bright bottom
cortel students from high income
families.
Uh,
we are a society in which the starting
in the wrong class makes it very
difficult to get through college and
that should not be the case.